Bonjour Jupiter is in tastic effect s'il
vous plait un cafe telephony I'd like
coffee please
oh thanks
hello everyone and welcome to the line
focused channel my name is Paul today I
am going to talk about the languages of
Switzerland Switzerland is a fascinating
country known for many things such as
the Swiss Alps Swiss chocolate Swiss
watches whis banking but it's also known
for being a multilingual nation and a
model of coexistence located at the
crossroads of Germany Austria France
Italy and Liechtenstein Switzerland has
four recognized national languages those
are German French Italian and Romansh
three of those German French and Italian
are official languages used by the state
but don't assume that everybody can
speak four languages Switzerland is a
Federation of 26 Canton's which are like
states with a high degree of autonomy
this federal type of government fits
well with Switzerland's multilingualism
at the national level
Switzerland is essentially trilingual in
German French and Italian that means
that for state purposes you can use any
of those three languages and those three
languages are used in Parliament and in
government offices Romansh is recognized
as a national language but it's not an
official language of administration
probably because there just aren't that
many speakers of Romansh the Swiss
Constitution guarantees linguistic
freedom for speakers of those four
national languages meaning that they are
free to use any of those languages to
communicate with each other or with the
government in their respective regions
because Switzerland's linguistic
communities are connected to specific
territories the federal government gives
each canton the right to choose its own
official language that affects which
language is used at school which
language is used at government offices
on radio broadcasts and TV all of those
sorts of things and in the Canton's that
have more than one official language the
Canton grants each municipality the
right to choose its own official
language that means that you sometimes
have one town with one official language
and the neighboring town with a
different one and there are even a
handful of bilingual municipalities that
provide services such as schools in both
languages depending on where you live in
that municipality now let's take a look
at each of the four national languages
the most widely spoken language is
German specifically Swiss German which
is spoken by five million
people or 63.5% of the population and
it's spoken in the largest area in
northern central and eastern switzerland
as well as on the Swiss plateau and part
of the Swiss Alps it is the official
language of 17 Canton's and it is Co
official in for more Canton's Swiss
German does not refer to one unified
language but rather to a group of
related alemannic dialects that are
spoken inside Switzerland these dialects
are not considered inferior to standard
German and they are used for all aspects
of daily life by basically all German
speakers Swiss German is generally
unintelligible to speakers of standard
German but it is intelligible to some
Germans who live across the border in
nearby areas who speak related dialects
and it's also understood by people in
Liechtenstein as well as border areas of
Austria
aside from spoken Swiss German dialects
there is also standard Swiss German
which is basically the same as the
standard German spoken in Germany in
Switzerland it is the written language
and all Swiss German speakers learn the
standard language in school but
basically in speech they almost
exclusively use Swiss German dialect as
I said before speakers of standard
German can't really understand Swiss
German and that includes Swiss people
who learn German as a second language in
school that causes problems because when
they travel to the german-speaking areas
they find that the German speakers speak
to them only in Swiss German dialect and
they can't understand it
well why doesn't the german-speaking
population make more of an effort to
speak standard German well according to
some sources I've read that was actually
happening but then when world war ii
broke out the swiss german population
wanted to be separate from germany they
wanted to be distinct so they started
de-emphasizing standard german and
relying more on their spoken dialects
the second most widely spoken language
is French with 1.8 million native
speakers or 22.5% of the population the
french-speaking region of Roman D is
located in western Switzerland on the
border with France the French language
in Switzerland differs very little from
the French language in France I've taken
lessons with some teachers in
Switzerland and I noticed very little
difference for example the number 70 in
France it's Wasabi's but in Switzerland
acceptant
also the number 9
in France its Cathy avanti's but in
Switzerland it's no Mount or the word
for breakfast in France it's petit
dejeuner
but in Switzerland it's dejeuner which
means lunch in France and in some areas
people use some German loanwords in
their French but basically the
differences are very minor
there are also some loanwords from
franco-provençal franco-provençal is an
unofficial regional language in France
and it is also still to some extent
spoken in some of the rural areas in
Switzerland but it has mostly become
replaced by a standard French so unlike
the situation of Swiss German and
standard German French speakers in
Switzerland really have no problem
communicating with French speakers in
France or in Belgium or elsewhere the
third most widely spoken language is
Italian with six hundred and forty five
thousand native speakers or eight point
one percent of the population it is an
official language and only one captain
called Ticino and it is one of three
official languages in one other canton
called graubünden both of those Canton's
are on the southern border with Italy
Swiss Italian is very similar to
standard Italian and there really are no
problems communicating between speakers
of those two varieties but there is a
different kind of accent or intonation
and there has been some influence of
Swiss German and the French on the
vocabulary a little bit and there's been
some influence of the original Italian
dialects of that area just like standard
French has grown to replace
franco-provençal standard Italian has
grown to replace the original Italian
dialect called teaching ease it is
actually quite different from standard
Italian and it could be considered its
own language it is still spoken to some
extent especially in rural areas and by
elderly people but it is basically being
overtaken by Swiss Italian the least
widely spoken of the four national
languages by a longshot is roll munch it
has only 40,000 native speakers or 0.5%
of the population there are immigrant
languages that have more speakers than
roll much serbo-croatian has almost
three times as many speakers as roll
munch it is an official language in only
one Canton and it's not the only one
it's one of three official languages
it's that Canton graubünden that I
mentioned before
Romansh is a Romance language that
developed from the spoken latin of the
roman empire but it was also influenced
by the local quelle
sikandra take languages of its region in
Switzerland it seems like a mystery why
Romansh is even a national language at
all because so few people speak it but
think about this in 1939 romich was made
an official language that was right
about the time when Hitler wanted to
incorporate all ethnic Germans inside
Germany and Mussolini wanted to include
all ethnic Italians inside Italy so
Switzerland might have felt nervous
about that and decided to emphasize that
they are a different country a
multilingual multi-ethnic country and
they showed that by making romich an
official language according to some
sources I've read that was the case
about 10% of the population speak other
languages those people are mostly
foreign workers or immigrants the
largest group is serbo-croatian with
about a hundred thousand speakers non
Swiss people often assume that Swiss
people are all Quadra lingual that they
can speak four languages but that's
rarely the case language use is highly
decentralized and it differs depending
on the region the canton and even the
town of course Swiss people speak their
own native language but then from the
third grade of elementary school they
have to study a different national
language that's usually French for
German speakers and German for everybody
else they also take English at school
and in high school they have to study a
third national language most Swiss
people say that they are not fluent in a
non-native national language but that
they can get by in one but people aren't
always very excited to speak a different
national language
I hear that French speaking Swiss people
don't really like to speak German and
vice-versa
in the old days they might have tried to
speak the other language but these days
some people just use English instead
English is becoming more and more
important in Switzerland because of
globalization and because of the
presence of more foreign companies in
the big cities many Swiss people these
days speak English better than they
speak any of the other national
languages so some people want to
emphasize English education in school
instead of other national languages and
basically make English the lingua franca
between the different linguistic
communities but some people don't like
that idea they think that that
undermines Switzerland's national
identity and their multi linguistic
character in the absence of a neutral
lingua franca like English or some other
language communication can be a tricky
issue an issue that's different
depending on the city and on the region
there are a handful of bilingual cities
along the Roche de grubbin in
Switzerland the Rosberg Robin is
basically the invisible linguistic
boundary between french-speaking and
german-speaking switzerland
in some of these bilingual cities on one
side of the river you have
french-speaking zones and on the other
side of the river you have
german-speaking zones cities like this
are typically not integrated the schools
are not bilingual they have separate
schools with languages for the different
communities so I want a city like that
when you meet someone from the other
side which language do you speak it's
always a tricky question there are some
multilingual Canton's but sometimes they
have disputes over linguistic policy or
linguistic identity and in one case a
whole new Canton was created to solve
the dispute the area of Jura was split
off from the canton of Bern in 1977 and
became its own Canton that is because
Jura was primarily french-speaking while
Bern was primarily german-speaking but
generally speaking the Swiss attitude
towards multilingualism seems to be one
of peaceful coexistence with separate
and distinct linguistic communities that
seems to be at the heart of what it
means to be Swiss the only problem is
everyone wants to speak their own
language and wait for the other side to
bridge the gap but since all of the
official languages are supposed to be
equal and no preference is supposed to
be shown then maybe a neutral lingua
franca like English would be the best
way to unite the different linguistic
communities these days some Canton's
want to stop teaching other national
languages as second languages and focus
instead on English and make that the
lingua franca do you think that's a good
idea let us know in the comments down
below and we'll discuss it
thank you for watching the Lange focus
Channel have a good day